hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action un leaches We are
continuing uh to play good chess and the
previous game wasn't all that impressive
so we're going to try to play uh a nicer
one this game uh let me just unpin the
Zen mode there we go our opponent is be
Resnik un 21 and he goes for E4 so we
will again strike with the Scandinavian
and he goes Knight to Knight to C3 so
everyone seems to be declining the
Scandinavian uh so capturing would
probably be something like um like a
fairly drawish territory D5 would be
seeking for Advantage but I'm not an
expert in advancing the pawn is I don't
face the this Declan one so I'm just
going to try to make it interesting I'm
just going to offer him to double my
pawns and I'm just going to put my
Bishop's
um okay we could pin the Knight doesn't
really do uh I I I don't think it's that
spectacular so I'm just going to put my
Bishops on D6 and E6 like like morphe
did and hope for the best all right
let's get our B okay
now not the best
maybe
yeah okay let's get the bishop in now
since he already wasted the move by
playing not wasted but he played it to
D3 so he's not going to bring it back to
E2 let's go Queen check he'll probably
decline the trade
H let's Castle Queen side or King side
do we play safe do we
play cuz he will get those pawns
marching forward really fast yeah let's
Castle King side not the not the most
spectacular as we are playing the
Scandinavian but
uh yeah let's go F5
here make room for our Queen Queen a
little
bit and also prepare F4 could be very
annoying for
him uh yeah let's do it let's do it you
want to capture on G4 I want to capture
on
E3 your
thing yeah you're going to move but now
my Bishop will be extra annoying here
since there is no G4
anytime
soon yeah I feel like we've both
misplayed it very very early on in the
opening so now we'll we'll just work
with what we
have uh what what could be a a viable
plan here he will probably play Queen to
C2 or something but not at the moment uh
so while this is happening he's not
going to play Queen to
C2 yeah okay that that works he he will
defend the the Knight this way so now
I'm I'm even considering
G5 yeah I'm definitely considering it it
it could be dangerous he does have the
bishop pair so my king could get in a
lot of
trouble uh but yeah I am considering
it yeah let's first uh get the Rooks
into the game since the bishop is here
we can maybe use it to double up
here is this
anything I don't think it is yeah he
okay he definitely
unpinned definitely unpinned
here
let's yeah it wasn't the best really
yeah he he really got out of it
nicely
let's see if he gives up the light
Square Bishop no he
doesn't okay I don't think he'll give up
the queen for two Rooks here but who
knows he actually might do
it it's probably even good here
it's probably even good
but yeah I don't think he'll do
it I don't think he'll do it and then
we'll just start uh shiting oh he will
do it okay yeah why not why
not yeah let's play C6 here trap is
Bishop
he doesn't have mate here because my
Bishop can Retreat so he will play
C4 C4 maybe to prepare this yeah he
doesn't want to allow me to push he
doesn't want to allow me the push but I
will play
G5 simply to have this defended at all
times
[Music]
um
let's go
C5
C5 yeah this is not very tricky he he
definitely has compensation uh the
question is how much compensation does
he
have
here cut off his Rooks maybe with
something like this in the
future especially if he goes go Rook D1
check maybe this will also weaken this
Pawn but I have to be careful of Bishop
C3 yeah it's very okay so he will give
one
check and now Bishop C3 could be
annoying yeah it could be could be very
annoying yeah how do you deal with
Bishop to
C3 he doesn't want to play
it he wants he wants what he wants me to
capture and then he's going to play
Bishop
here yeah why not why
not
um but I can just capture like
this
okay King H2 was probably better this is
uh I think he's playing uh quite a lot
of suboptimal moves here yeah could have
played that a lot better we're going to
check after the game yeah we're going to
take the free piece and now he really
has no
compensation okay so not going to go
Pawn grabbing or anything like that
let's
um probably there's a there's a really
clean way of ending things
here just move the Knight deliver a
check and then get the Knight into the
game some other
way
yeah this this will
do and now
this okay so he
he's defending very
nicely
uh so we're just going to since I I
really have nothing to worry about here
I'm just going to play uh W with the
G4 but probably there is some sort of a
some sort of a tricky mate here although
I last time I I
tried uh spending my time and trying to
find the sneaky mate uh I just
lost guess so let's yeah it's also
possible to play like
this
and now Knight here will will get the
job
done yeah okay that was uh I mean it was
interesting but
uh he he probably yeah that's how he
will defend
okay um so now we'll just we're just
going to go through
here
okay uh I had m in one but I I I have it
all the time so that's not a problem
okay so we won here uh our opponent
wants a rematch okay so we'll play a
rematch here and then we'll going to
we're going to uh analyze the previous
game
uh since uh I I I it's pretty pretty
short game yeah like 9 Minutes uh into
it so we we can play another one okay
okay so we play Knight F3 as that is the
opening that potentially leads us to the
Evans Gambit so if it happens it happens
if not he will probably go Knight
F6 yeah and we'll go Knight
G5 we won the first game Let's Play
Let's play something interesting okay
let's Capt on D5 the two Knight's
defense he goes for the standard stuff
as
expected and uh I've I've I've been
experimenting with Knight D3 a little
bit with Bishop to D3 a little bit also
I've tried some Queen F3 ideas here but
uh Bishop D2 does appear to be the most
solid yeah okay we're going to go back
so this is like the the oldest of the
oldest some Bishop D6 queen queen
D5 um not familiar with this particular
move but I don't think it changes
anything yeah let's go
F4 ah and now Bishop to C5 that's the
the reason why I do it in this
particular
order yeah okay I'm uh very interested
in seeing what it happens okay so now if
I play Knight C3 he will just play Queen
D4 is that the
point so let's play C3 so okay you show
me what's what's the point
okay so he had to move otherwise we'd
win material here with Pawn to
B4 but yeah his Bishop is very nice here
I like his Bishop here
definitely so how do we how do we get
into the game here B4 B4 always wins the
game and it does so here because now
comes Bishop
C4 yeah and it nicely connects to
F7 now we can even play Knight captures
we don't have to play Bishop
captures yeah then he captures on
F4 he gives up a rook for some sort of a
nasty attack yeah let let's just play
Bishop captures on F7 be safe about it
yeah that's how we'll do
it that's how we'll do
it
H this is very very wild stuff
here let's play
C4 close off that uh dark Square
Bishop it's such a such a nice open
game of course he'll do
that yeah serves me right for playing C4
there but okay it's not not bad that
that big of a deal go
C5 I has to be a little bit careful if
he goes here yeah might
even okay
so I sort of blundered the bishop here
but not
really because if he
if he takes here I take here and then
his Knight is attacked as uh really
really wild
game so uh I still think I'm better here
he probably did
something something weird with putting
the Knight on B7 like this not being
able to enter the game okay so he
doesn't go for any captures he he wants
to be safe here he doesn't want to allow
Knight to G6 check which is of
course of course he shouldn't but uh I
I'm not going to allow that I'm just
going to even Knight captures on C6 is
very strong here yeah I can just attack
the queen and then pick up the
bishop so many many moves here that are
sort of
nice
h
yeah but this is he's constantly
preventing me from castling that's very
annoying yeah this is nice I believe
but what what
then and then the bishop just moves with
his Queen on D4 I can bring my Bishop
back here King yeah I think this is
actually the way to go
Bishop G6 was
nice uh but I think it's better to just
eliminate the dark Square
Bishop yeah again I'm I'm spending a lot
of time here let's just take
here and Bishop D5 even yeah put
pressure on that annoying Knight not the
I don't want to give him
time okay so of course I blundered that
yeah of course I blundered that yeah oh
he doesn't even want to take the Rook
he's that nice oh he wants me to Castle
and then give a check yeah not not
happening all right so we are still in
the game although not as much as we were
since we've lost a
piece uh he stops us from castling he
wants to capture this
Pawn uh all right do we have anything
here that we can use the sort of exploit
his King being on
f8 yeah let's
uh let's play A3
first and then we're going to get the
Rook into the game and the Queen and so
on so okay you can play that yeah he
probably wants to play some
E3
yeah we're not going to allow that just
yet you will have to work for your meal
sir yeah I'm not worried about being
down a pawn because I mean these pawns
are the these pawns are really nice here
yeah now he wants to play this so we
will prevent
it and it also stops his King from
escaping so this is not taken care of
and now we are
threat yeah we're not threatening
anything I actually just allowed him to
capture my
Pawn but it's
fine
yeah
nice very nice yeah he will give a check
again uh but still he has to figure out
how to get out of this if
he I don't imagine he will be interested
in a Perpetual
here that is something I I could not
imagine so how do
I yeah he's uh no doubt he's completely
winning here oh he wants to trade down
okay we will trade
down not all the way of
course not all the way
but what if I want to trade down all the
way can give a check okay he he he's
going to go
there yeah he needs he needs to waste a
move if he wants to push the pawn and
that will give me just enough time or he
has to waste a move defending the pawn
and then again that gives me enough time
to take control over the D2
Square H yeah again I again I put myself
in a position that's just ugly to look
at or if or if I play yeah he's going to
defend it this way but now I'm I might
even be looking in
H3 so if he pushes the
pawn no I have to stop
I have to stop
D2 yeah
unfortunately I have to stop
D2 okay so he doesn't allow me anything
here and he's threatening mate so we're
going going to have to play
this an end game where I believe he's
completely winning but uh
let's let's check just to be
sure let's go after the
bishop he will take here I will put the
Rook behind the past Pawn he will maybe
give some
checks oh he will stop my advancement of
course can I take yeah I can take
H okay down one but others will
advance no they won't
H yeah the bishop Knight combo here is
doing quite quite the
job let's uh let's at least keep his
Rook
here
okay I will take the bishop thank
you there we go I believe we are back I
believe we are back yeah we can't only
have bad
luck uh we also should have some good
luck yeah let's take this Pawn as
well yeah I'm I'm looking at that move
and I'm positive that he cannot do it
and yet he does it it's
unbelievable
unbelievable yeah of course he will do
it
yeah sad sad stuff and now he's just up
a
pawn
great great
stuff it's okay oh he's going to be up
one more Pawn Yeah that's
great that's
great
all right so unless we have some sort of
Perpetual here we're just losing
this yeah checks are no no longer
possible because he has all all all the
checks to stop any of my checks so we're
just going to have
to play this out and hope for Hope for
something although there's nothing to
hope for here anymore it's just going to
push the pawn and that's
it
okay so he gives me
one ah but his King is so so
close yeah if I can't kick was King then
he will of course get an easy draw uh an
easy
win yeah that's pretty much it is there
something at least that we can play I
don't think
so I don't think
so
H just King
F1 King F1 and that's
it no it's not
but yeah is going to give a check
okay yeah now if he goes here I can
Checkmate him that'd be great so he will
have to figure out how to get get the
pawn
in
okay I I have nothing but to
repeat okay what's uh what would be the
tricky way to play this okay let's put
the queen here King here so he cannot
get the king out
anywhere okay so he just goes back
okay
there's no way for me to actually win
this unless he plays uh plays in sort of
a self mate but uh maybe if he if he's
not careful maybe I can draw this yeah
okay we
repeat okay it's a three-fold
repetition okay so uh that was uh very
nice uh let me just check on the
previous
game yeah the one that we played uh we
said that we were going to analyze it
just to see uh what was what was so
interesting here okay a standard
Scandinavian uh where I said that we
probably played something weird in the
opening but no this is still perfectly
fine F5 yeah okay F5 is
weird uh he countered it with H3 okay F4
now he moves the bishop yeah Bishop
captures on F4 was better and then
capturing but who would who would know
that okay so this is fine fine
fine uh pretty much a draw okay Knight
H5 actually a blunder Queen B5 Bishop
captures captures and now Knight C6 Rook
ah Rook captures on E8 was
better uh yeah so just B4 don't don't
give up the queen for The Rook yeah that
was uh not the best but even this is
perfectly playable still a drawn
position yeah it's fine fine fine fine
okay so now uh after this check yeah
King H1 that's the one that we mentioned
was uh the the losing move if he plays
King H2 it's still playable uh but now
yeah there's nothing here okay that's
pretty pointless and this one sorry
the the one that we played uh against
him let me just check here
just check here sorry is leeches down
yeah no it's not okay so this is the
second one that we've
played uh the one where he couldn't
finish me
off uh sorry let me just uh flip the
flip the board I don't know why it's
flipped this
way uh yeah that's the one okay so
let me just check here computer
analysis okay so yeah Queen D5 is weird
Okay so D4 yeah I always get confused
here do do I play D4 first or F4 first
so D4 first was better but F4 also not a
problem Bishop C5 I played C3 and here
B4 yeah and like I said I'm already
winning here but for some reason I
didn't win uh C4 yeah Knight A3 better
this just allowed this but still it's
winning for white so where did I make
the crucial mistake that allowed him to
gain the opport ah just Bishop D5 yeah I
mean of course I did blunder a piece but
still this is z00 territory yeah still
Queen B3 actually yeah the losing move
for me just Queen C1 here and it's
perfectly
fine yeah this was uh this was pretty
bad and then yeah still winning still
winning still winning for him everything
is winning for him yeah and now after he
blunders this now I'm winning now I
blunder my Rook so he's winning and now
we get this position here
where he blunders the pawn and now it's
sort of winning drawish winning drawish
but no this is completely winning for
him and here we agree to draw in a
three-fold repetition but the way to win
as leeches will point out now is this
and if I continued playing what I
usually play Then King comes out and
then you promote the pawn so it's not uh
nothing
spectacular uh so yeah that's pretty
much it um I played two games uh none of
them were really good but in the end I
got a win in the draw so what are you
going to do I you know sometimes it
works out sometimes it doesn't uh hope
you enjoyed that see you
soon